We're starting off the work week
with news about the work week.
It might be getting shorter.
"Bloomberg Business" reports
that companies around the world are trying to figure out
the four-day work week.
One Berlin tech company tried it during lockdown,
paying employees exactly the same amount
for four days, instead of five.
And they found that by the numbers,
sales, employee engagement,
and client satisfaction all increased.
In fact, 2/3 of all the companies who have tried this
says it's increased employee productivity.
Ross, we've been doing
the five-day work week over here for 100 years.
Is it time to shave a day off the week?
I think we are just so trained,
in like, no, we work Monday through Friday.
We've been doing it forever, that it's sort of scary.
But when you look at these stats, you just,
you can't deny that there's something there.
I wonder now, if this is the best time to re-examine it,
because of the pandemic, because of Zoom,
because we're all doing things in a more technological way.
This is the moment.
Agreed, and well, a three-day weekend
would leave plenty of time for stuff like dating.
Yeah, and it appears that in 2021,
singles are ready to mingle.
"People" reports a new poll, by PlentyofFish,
which is a dating app, survey-
With the cutest name ever.
Daters, yeah, and they surveyed daters,
and they found more than half of them out there
felt confident that this is the year
they would find the one.
People are optimistic.
The survey found that people are feeling more romantic,
and more open to the idea
that they might not have considered other people before.
I think it's just really this,
I think people have been locked inside for so long,
that by the time we get out there,
our standards are going to be a little lower.
(laughing) So we're just going to be like,
"Um, are you physically here?
Okay, I think I love you."
(laughing) One of the other things
that I think the article mentions
is that people are starting to reevaluate
their exes again, like we're at that point.
Yeah, where it's like, "Hm, you know, he wasn't that bad,
now that it's been like a year since I've been touched."
Yeah exactly
(laughing)
Right?
I do love the notion
that people are feeling more optimistic and romantic,
if not desperate (laughing).
And I'll say, I'll say this,
maybe this is the year to find a one, if not the one.
Do you even believe in the one?
I mean, that's like a heavy thing.
No.
(laughing)
I believe in not scaring yourself
into thinking that you might have already had the one,
or to put all the stock into one person,
that they have to fulfill everything for you.
There will be loves, there will be chapters,
and each and every one of them
might add up to something amazing.
You said it could be like just a chapter,
and it could be a really long chapter,
if you're with someone for a long time.
But I love the idea of just removing that pressure,
of this is the one, it's gotta be the one.
And you know, maybe you can have multiple ones.
You can have multiple ones,
and for those people who lock it down,
and are happy forever,
as long as they both shall live, wonderful.
Like there is no right or wrong.
Mhm, agreed.
Agreed.
You're my one, Rossy.
Am I, I am? Yeah, I don't feel any pressure.
(laughing)
Move over, Wellington.
Well, the pandemic has also affected
the way that we see fashion.
I mean, it has been a year of homey comfort.
Hello, elastic.
I know.
And now "InStyle" reports
that the latest on-trend color reflects that.
The color you must work into your wardrobe immediately is,
ready, drum roll.
(hands banging)
Potato brown
M'kay, no.
From couch potato, to the trend in fashion,
there's so many ways to wear it, it's a neutral.
So you can pair it with bright neons, or a bold print.
Or if you want that full head-to-potato look-
Oh no, you didn't.
Yes, I did.
You can go monochromatic with it.
And I've definitely dabbled
in some potato brown on this show.
Check out our Instagram,
because you can actually break down all the looks
that the genius Lee Harris, who's the stylist on this show,
and you can buy everything,
all these great suggestions and how-tos,
and wear, shop the look, if you will.
Ross, are you gonna shop for some spud duds or what?
Well, okay, I try to coordinate with you
every single day, right?
And so when I'm backstage and the show starts,
I'm watching and I say, "Oh, what's she gonna wear?
What's she gonna wear?"
And when you wear potato, that's when I freak out.
(laughing)
Because, you know what I look like if I wear a potato?
A potato, that's what I look like, right?
No matter how you slice and dice me, I look like a potato.
And so like when you wear this, for example,
I get very, very excited,
because I've had this in my,
been on my rack back there waiting,
and look how cute we look.
I think you are just minty fresh-
Thank you.
And beautiful.
Thank you for noticing.
Crisp.
You can pull off a potato, I, not so much.
I look like a walking tater tot.
Well, oh God, I love tater tots,
that just made me want one.
Let me tell you something,
a tater tot is the most underrated potato product.
And I proudly said it for years.
I love the potato tater tot.
(happy music)
♪ Oh ♪